خالد جدران متحدث باسم قياده الامن في
العاصمه كابول يعترف بان عناصر من تنظيم
داعش اختفوا في البلاد بعدما دخل الطالبان
العاصمه وقامت بكسر ابواب السجون التابعه
للنظام السابق التي كان يقمع فيها عدد من
معتقل التنظيم
قواتنا الامنيه جاده في التصدي لجميع
العناصر الشريره التي تهدد الامن وتضايق
المواطنين نحن نقوم باحتقالهم وقتلهم
حيثما ظهرنا بهم
مهاجر فراهي وكيل بوزاره الثقافه والاعلام
الافغانيه يؤكد عمليات الدواعش بين حين
واخر ويصف اياها بانها متقطعه لا تؤدي الى
زعزعه الامن بحسب تعبيره
في بلد يعيش فيه اربعون مليون شخص من
الطبع ان تحدث فيها عمليه امنيه خلال شهر
ولن نستطيع وصف الوضع بان الامن انعدم
تماما فان مثل هذه العمليات قد تحدث في
جميع بلاد العالم
في عمليات مضاده نفذتها القوات الامنيه
خلال شهر فقط قتل ابو عبيده الكشميري امير
داعش لشبه القاره الهنديه والقارئ فاتح
مسؤول العمليات القتاليه لداعش فرع خراسان
على الرغم من عمليات دمويه يقوم بها تنظيم
داعش في البلاد فان السلطات في كابول لا
تعتبر التنظيم تهديدا خطرا وذلك لان عناصر
التنظيم لم تستطع السيطره حتى الان على
شبر من الاراضي الافغانيه عبد القادر
العربيه كابول